I wanted to address a couple things I
very rarely get to speak and I
unfortunately always get put at the last
slot at this conference so before I
actually got into my talk I wanted to
address a couple things in our community
last year I gave talk at this point that
we need to change our community so I
wanted to take this chance before my
actual talk to address some of the
issues that I'm sure we all have
questions about I'm sure we were all
hoping that Eric or Brendan would
mention certain words that they didn't
so I want to I want to just talk about
those real quick the first one would be
the obvious elephant in the room from a
leaked email with pure speculation and
that being dark dark is awesome I think
we as developers has javascript
developers as web developers should
embrace dart and I'm not saying give up
ever give up JavaScript and just go
running to dart land because we don't
even know what dart land is everything
we've heard about at this point is pure
speculation the web is a massive place
historically speaking if you look at the
track records the only thing that has
happened when new languages crop off is
that JavaScript gets better so don't go
spreading negativity about Dart don't
even worry about it until you actually
know what it is speculation doesn't help
anything fighting over speculation helps
even less so what I have to say about
dart is cool let's see what it looks
like if it's great and we all embrace it
then it's great because we all embrace
it if it's not great and it ends up not
working well we'll just merge it in like
we did tamarin and everything will be
great and will all move on so let's not
get all wrapped around the axle on
speculation
did you learn if you want to take away
to let you sleep better at night is Tom
Robinson here where did he go drinking
already ah there Tom had a wonderful
accidental quote is what i'll call it
tom has experienced we don't know him he
helped right he helped all fair
objective j which is a language on top
of javascript and his quote was it is a
lot to ask of people to learn and to use
a whole new language that's a pretty
interesting thing when you think about
it even though we all learn new
languages it is a lot to ask so bear
that in mind with dart let's see what
the world has to offer i encourage us to
embrace new languages mozilla has rust
they're doing amazing things google has
possibly dark dashed it's something
beginning of d so let's not be afraid of
these new languages let's embrace them
let's see what they have to offer and as
JavaScript developers let's see what
they can do to benefit our language and
make our lives better and that leads me
to my next topic the open web I have a
unique position I get to hang out with
alex russell and brendan eich and have
dinner with some crazy people it's a
unique position for me because I'm not a
browser vendor I actually don't really
have much stake in this game I'm a
start-up founder who helps nursing homes
and assisted living which probably some
people in this room that my the benefit
i have is that I get to look at this web
this magical place what all of you are
doing and say wow the battling the not
battling the the energy the excitement
the creativity the innovation the
invention is going on in our space is so
incredibly amazing when we started in
2009 the world was a lot different place
and it's because we live in an open web
these days where there isn't a monarchy
instilled and there are multiple
browsers and there are people pushing
the fold and we are doing crazy things
that sometimes seem counterproductive
but in the end this is the web this is
the magic that we all came to this for
so hooray open web
which goes to my next talk or next quick
button item promote jas last year we
launched that here and we've done an
amazing job if you haven't looked at our
we first yet we have managed to get
every single search term we were
targeting on the first page of a google
search index that's pretty frickin
impressive but as christian how am I
mentioned that's not nearly enough how
many of you participated in the docs
print that was going on this weekend
that's embarrassing okay I want everyone
as a mission for as much as you want to
go drinking tonight the cost for
drinking tonight is going on to the mdn
and modifying a doc doesn't have to be
that much just try it break into it
enjoy it go for it it's a shared
document repository it's a wiki anyone
go into it you can add stuff about about
Google specific components you can add
stuff about Microsoft specific
components you can add stuff about opera
specific components and of course was a
little bit like if you added stuff about
mdn or mozilla as well so use this let
this be our center point let this be a
place where we can all come together and
we can all agree on documentation the
next piece is something that I really
want to inspire everyone here when you
leave this place let this not be a
single point in time let this be
something that has changed you let the
presentations today is something that
you carry and inspires you and that you
bring back to your local communities
after the last 2 3gs comps that we've
done in each continent at this point
it's been amazing to see the explosion
of different local user groups and
meetups that have popped up and that is
wonderful how many of you out there run
or attend a local meetup a big round of
applause to all of you
another cool thing in a cool statistic
is this weekend we've been able to
introduce or really push the boundaries
of JavaScript to over a thousand people
we have a group assembled here there's a
jquery conf going on in ballston want to
say it's either Boston or San Francisco
and that's a lot of people that are
using javascript and coming to
conferences that's very impressive so we
need something to really brandish
ourselves and we we've been subversive a
little bit we've been giving out
stickers and doing these sorts of things
and JavaScript's never had an identity
we had a rhino for a little bit but that
doesn't really seem so good right now
that we're kicking tail and being really
fast so you know what you may hate this
logo and that's cool but I'm gonna say
let's just use it it's simple it works
it doesn't really appeal to any browser
vendor it's awesome it's our logo it's
only other laptops already and we're
honest cell phones so i'm making this
fully publicly available in raw format
HTTP colon slash slash jazz conf calm /
jst PS if you want to use it great if
you don't great it's up to you we'll
call it a community logo or not it's
just an offer and that's my offer so I'm
actually gonna get into my talk I
promise you um that's sort of my
overview of the world I want to reset
the everything we move forward um Thank
You Ryder for the tweet I wish that
hadn't popped up um I'd like to have Jed
Schmidt and John David Dalton come to
the stage nope
both of them
I've got two chairs here one free to you
but you get sit down yeah just sit down
you got new seats yes sit down sit down
these guys are great guys so they're
gonna help me out with my presentation
so we're at the images cough and
everyone's upbeat and they're ready to
go change the world and how many of you
are ready just go out of here and drink
and change the world and go woo sort of
like multi was dancing last night Barry
yeah exactly I don't get to speak very
much in fact the last time I actually
spoke was in Berlin at JS con for you
it's a unique position to be conference
organizer and not be able to ever really
talk so when I do get a chance to speak
i'm gonna talk about things i want to
talk to you directly about the issues
and problems that I see with our
community if you hate those kind of
talks I'm sorry we had a whole day full
of technical stuff um I'm not gonna just
offer my perspective on what's wrong I'm
gonna try to give solutions they may be
horrible solutions because I am not
perfect I don't even adhere to all the
solutions I suggest i am not a person
who actually should even be here making
these suggestions but i'm just trying to
start the discussion so people like
yourselves who are better to solve these
solutions can go forward with them I
haven't really ever I haven't always
been like this I used to speak about
technical content node serial port stuff
like that but all that changed when I
unfortunately didn't see video but all
that changed when I watched and
witnessed the birth of my little
daughter it is an impressive moment and
really something that changes your
entire world fatherhood has an amazing
way of kicking you in the ass and
helping you to see really what matters
in this world and so it's because that
reason that I'm here to talk to you
today all my desk at work is a little
metal plaque it engraved on it is the
words what would you do if you knew you
could not fail
I'm gonna say that again if you wouldn't
mind just playing along with me and
close your eyes when I say I'd greatly
appreciate it what would you do if you
knew you could not fail the co-worker of
mine gave this to me this plaque to me
when I was just out of college young kid
I thought it was worthless threw it in
the bottom of my desk drawer pretty much
assumed it was a tchotchke that I'd
never use and then over the course of a
couple years I pulled it back out and I
put it on my desk and I'd look at it and
I kept thinking you know is something to
that what if we couldn't fail what would
we do and so I ended up deciding to
dedicate my life to that sorter that
very simple saying what would I do if I
knew I couldn't fail I right now run a
start-up I throw seven conferences a
year I have one hell of a job as a
flower delivery guy because my wife runs
a floral design business and I have the
incredible honor and privilege to be
raising a beautiful baby girl I do all
this because I kind of throw caution and
a lot of good advice to the wind I try
to live life to the fullest and as most
you probably know if you've been out at
the parties I generally tell sleep to
you know sleepy damned and just try to
take life all in one thing has plagued
me when you do when you live this sort
of life when you say what happens if I
could do anything I want and I will not
fail you put yourself out there in great
risk entrepreneurs this culture that we
live in is very entrepreneurial focused
we are a risk-taking people we have to
be we are unlike any other industry in
the world we can take nothing open up
our laptop create magic in under a day
in 3d too
by a show of hands how many of you were
on a company or have run a company or
work in a company of Grigor of less than
20 okay how many of you have open source
software or hardware awesome all of you
are risk takers that raised your hand
and those that didn't you are risk
takers as well at heart now I know it
otherwise you wouldn't be here I mean
party last night was a big risk and be a
risk taker means you have opened
yourself up to a great deal of exposure
you've put yourself out there when you
open source something when you put
something out in public I that's a part
of yourself a part of your soul a part
of your spirit that is out there in the
open most people don't know this but
James conf was a huge mistake when I say
hellooo when I started jazz comp my wife
and I um we didn't started thinking hey
let's create an amazing conference we
started accidentally with me at a bar
saying I want to go to a JavaScript
conference I didn't find one so instead
of ticket sales we sold four tickets
over two months as those of you who know
conference over who have organized a
conference for tickets to two months is
not a good thing we were having to sign
on the hotel where we did the first
years come from we were putting our
entire lives at stake meanwhile hacker
news everyone was trashing us because we
have no idea what we're doing were
idiots this is a horrible idea we signed
the lease on the hotel at the same time
we marked it as sold out or we were
about to send Elise we mark the
conference's sold out because I was
trying to pull out and save face I was
gonna refund all the tickets and walk
away I share this story with you because
a lot of people think jazz cough comes
naturally and we put a lot of risk into
it and we do everything we can to make
it as crazy as possible because we
believe that's what you want and that's
what we want to give
to you when we marked it as sold out
everyone bought a ticket yay so luckily
I didn't get a divorce after that which
was a great thing but it's something
that that people have asked me numerous
times how did you come up with this idea
and it's complete and total dumb luck we
are risk takers we are all risk-takers
and that means we put our souls out
there and we put ourselves out there and
i quickly mentioned it but we have
failed each other in doing this we as
developers as designers as friends have
failed one another I have watched
negativity hate no I know this is just
to listen don't watch this is playing
negativity hate sarcasm completely and
totally dominate our community and our
world and I am just as guilty as
everybody else so I'm not coming here as
somebody who's doing it right we we
allow this to happen so much so that we
even have words for local isms for it
called trolling you guys have heard of
this by a show of hands how many of you
have experienced being trolled that is a
lot of people when you experience this a
part of your soul a part of you a part
of your energy dies and I hate that
because all of this leads to is stifling
innovation preventing invention ruining
our risk-taking ability but most of all
it kills our ability to be happy
developers and it's not random people
doing it it's ourselves doing it to
ourselves many say they love jazz comp
because we come together as a family we
may joke with one another and we may rib
each other but we know that we're all
friends and we leave
better friends and almost like a family
that's why we do the group photo at the
end it sickens me every time I leave
jazz conf we are here with so much
energy and so much happiness and really
we leave wanting to change the world and
then we'll get home and we'll open up
hacker news or we'll open up right it
will open up IRC or we'll open up github
issue 28 and we'll see this trolling
this evil this negativity this battling
all over the place and it really makes
you say why should I keep doing it every
time after a jazz cough I'd look to
laura and i say i'm not doing this ever
again I can't bring myself to go through
this again and I'm sure that those you
who've raised her hand have felt that
way at some point in time I've watched
social networks rise and
disproportionately destroy our social
human networks our friendships are
colleagues the fake anonymity of the web
has been turned into a platform for
promoting self-worth at the cost of
everything and everyone that runs
contrary to that person when our friends
launched something or release something
into this firing squad the best we can
do is we can can console them with words
like you have to have a tough skin or
haters gonna hate today I'm going to
call on that we need to stop
blaming victims we need to understand
the risk that others take and understand
that we will or we are all taking
similar risks as well last year I made a
call to improve our community this year
I'd like to make a new coal that we
improve ourselves and we be the change
that we want to see in the world
following along from last year how many
of you code in PHP have how many you
have coated in Ruby Python Perl see
algal
how many of you think any of that
matters so why do we have battles
these are tools they are not religions
we need to understand that and we need
to believe within that we need to commit
to what is right and not what feels good
we are a family here outside in our
community we are a family of developers
when I talk to people about the magic
that is jazz conf I'm not talking about
the amazing food I'm not talking about
the crazy parties I'm not talking about
the beer available whenever you want it
what I'm talking about is that sense of
when you leave and it's almost like
you're leaving grandmas house and your
brothers and sisters are there and
you've met everyone and god it feels so
good and at any moment you could call it
Nikolai and say dude how do I make the
Russian and he'll help you out he'll
probably ship it to you but I'm not
coming here just to say this is what's
wrong peace I'm here to try to offer
some solutions or at least ideas like
last year my intent is not to solve all
of the world's problems all of the time
but at least to give you all a spark
that you can light a fire with and go
home and maybe we can all change this so
here's the first of my suggestions I'm
gonna call it kids in the back and this
comes from discussing with the man back
there and a man who isn't here Brendan
and Alex Alex Russell those two like to
have discussions people like to get
involved in their discussions so what I
made the suggestion of is when they are
get into one of these discussions I'm
gonna suggest kids in the back if it
gets above three thread balance what
that means is hey just like if you're
driving in a car and you have the kid in
the back and you and your spouse are
driving driving you know I don't really
like McDonald's well I love McDonald
with that animosity that fighting the
kids see that and they learn this and so
we as as role models and you don't even
know her role models but we are role
models we need to understand that there
are kids in the back who are watching us
seeing what we do thinking that's
acceptable behave
here and we need to discipline ourselves
to say there are kids in the back why
don't we go out out of band
communication and talk directly I don't
think that's asking too much that if we
have something that gets very heated you
take it off of a public channel then
people aren't fighting with pride they
don't have to show themselves and be
better just to pound their chests call
each other up we do have these things
called telephones they still work I
tried it doesn't work with the video but
does to Paul's mom I need you come to an
agreed-upon solution then post that back
up because you know what resolution is
great if you don't come up with a
resolution just let the three comments
it the internet disappears very quickly
but it does not forget the other is a
discussion of public versus private we
should honor respect and be very
positive in public the two gentlemen up
here do absolutely amazing things and
that's why I wanted them both to come up
they are some of the best people that we
have in the community they're pushing
boundaries they're doing amazing things
so thank you
you guys can go back if you want or you
can sit here it's up to you you guys can
go back to your seat if you want or you
can stay here it's up to you i just
wanted to all right good now i know that
in javascript we don't really have a
concept of private variables so what
we're gonna do is we're going to closure
the next um negative comments negative
discussions anything that might be
negative we can just take those into
them private let's separate those bands
of communication when you talk to
someone privately about an issue when
you come up and say hey I have an issue
with something that you said you'll be
quite impressed at how much better the
communication happens if you do it on
the internet it always goes bad the next
suggestion be willing to stand up to the
haters and I'm not talking about the
person who's getting hated on I'm
talking about instead of telling our
friends they gotta suck it up and deal
with it be there to say hey I see that
you have a problem why don't we talk
about it instead of you in them I'm much
more better because I'm not connected to
that but I this is my friend let's talk
every attack every negative comment is
one more thing preventing us from taking
risks from living out the earlier quote
from living life as if we could not fail
and remember and think back to when you
had your eyes closed what could you do
if you knew you couldn't fail a wise man
once said on this continent his name was
Theodore Roosevelt he was a president of
the United States he gave a speech
called citizenship in the Republic in
1910 I'm going to read this because I
want to get it exactly right but I want
you just to listen to it it is not the
critic who counts not the man who points
out how the strong man stumbles or where
the doer of Deeds could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
is act
in the arena whose face is marred with
dust and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who heirs who comes short
again and again because there is no
effort without error and shortcoming but
who does actually strive to do the deeds
he who knows great enthusiasms the great
devotions who spends himself any worthy
cause Who at the best knows in the end
the triumph of high achievement and who
had the worst if he fails at least fails
while daring greatly so that his place
shall never be with those cold timid
souls who neither know victory nor
defeat we have to stop the negativity we
have to change our world we have to
start by changing ourselves if there is
one thing you take away from this talk
there's one thing you do please do this
when you see someone taking the risk
when you see someone being the man or
woman in the arena when their face is
bloody and marred and dirty stand up
next to them support them talk to the
people who are coming at them talk to
the critics but do it and this is key do
it with positivity and not more hate
come together as friends and not as
enemies because the person in the arena
is already fighting a battle and if you
address the other person and not to me
to him he's just there if you address
the other person as a friend with
positivity like hey you want to go get a
beer because that seemed a little bit
harsh is something the matter we could
talk it out no worries every time I've
done this with someone i found out that
what was what happened was somebody was
negative on
where someone said their projects sucked
or they wrote a long run a wrong line of
code and it perpetuates and spins the
cycle but one thing I've learned is that
if we stand up and we say hey it's okay
that line of code was also let's not go
fight not anyone else once you do that
we can turn the tide back and we can
bring happiness innovation invention and
pride and most importantly our happiness
and fulfillment into this industry this
will be very hard to do the first couple
times you attempt it because most people
stand up and and just want to be
negative when they want to be negative
but if you do this if you do this for a
colleague then you're doing it for all
the rest of us as well and in return I
can ensure you that we will be doing it
for you just the same and so I'd like to
wish you a good night and thank you very
much for being part of this family